hello everyone I'm Ambrose boner
sergeant and today and welcome to to my
talk and this is type closure in
practice so for the first few minutes
I'm going to have to ask you to keep
your brain switched on and I'm going to
be quizzing you throughout the this
introduction so when we see this closure
logo I hope you can see it's kind of
shadowed in the background maybe you
can't but I'll tell you when it's
closure and untyped closure type closure
and untyped closure so this is just a
simple function that has it has two era
T's and basically what it does it takes
either nil or a non empty collection and
then returns an integer that that
summarizes that collection so it's
basically a hashing function so it has
an interesting loop invariant which is
that the end seek this first argument
has to always be nil or a non empty
vector non-empty collection rather so
let's run this code okay all right
that's a summarizing meal and we get
back 42 so what happens if we try and
summarize a vector so what's the worst
thing that can happen in Java give me
one thing what's even worse than that oh
my god well done
so this is what we actually get if we
run this code and instead of using
closure to debug this let's convert this
to type closure and find the bug so the
first thing to do when converting
closure to type closure is to add a
namespace dependency to our closure code
and yeah you can't see the type closure
logo so this is now typed code so we run
the type checker and we get back some
errors so the first time we run a type
that run the type checker over some code
the we're very likely to get this error
which is an unattainable and this tells
us that type closure uses local type
inference which means that we have to
provide annotations for our top level
definitions so let's do that for
summarize so we annotate summarize the
first arity takes nil or a non-empty
collection events and returns in it and
the second arity is the same but it has
an extra accumulator int but you know
there's some parentheses overload so
let's convert the the this common type
into an alias and we'll call it an int
sore neela blintz and if you can't read
the the the type annotation you can also
add a doc string to death
alias so you can read it English in
English and then convert it to to type
closure types so an int is nil or a
persistent non-empty collection events
so let's type check this code so we get
a little more productive error than
cannot find the type of summarize this
time is complaining about a particular
invocation of summarize this is a
function application error this means
that a particular application of a
function is being passed bad arguments
first thing you do when you see this
this error is compare the domains which
are the expected types for the function
to the arguments which are the actual
types being Converter being passed here
and the the invocation in question here
is the one underlined so what we do we
compare an inch to a seeker vent and
there's our problem we try to give a
possibly empty seek to something that
expects a nillable or non-empty seek of
integers so we're actually using the
wrong function
in our a recursive call there's a very
subtle difference between two functions
that I'm about to explain to you so
there's this rest function it's a
sequence function it takes any C Keable
or nil as you can see from the the red
type annotation at the top so for all X
takes nil or a sequel of X and returns a
seek of X and you can see the actual
behavior in these examples so this is
always going to be a true value so
that's where our stack overflow kept
going because our loop invariant assumed
that the collection was going to be nil
or a false value and then the recursion
would stop so actually there's a
different function called next which is
the one that we want so let's read the
type for next for all types X takes nil
or say Keable of X and returns nil or a
non empty sake of X so this is actually
much closer to what we want so let's
check the example to see if it actually
is so if we have the next of an empty
vector and the next of nil we get we get
new which is a false value and this will
terminate our recursion so let's add
this and type check great it worked so
back to our untyped closure buffer so
the the top line says summarize the
three element vector and we get back
this number great okay this is looking a
bit more like a hashing algorithm now we
can summarize nil great we've got 42 you
know but it would be nice to be able to
summarize empty vectors so who wants to
guess what happens now we've had we've
had Stack Overflow
what's the second worst thing no point
Oh bang again let's fix this with type
closure so here's our invocation at the
top summarize the empty vector and type
closure tells us we've actually passed
an empty vector where we're expecting
Anila balloons so you can just to remind
you there's the definition of nillable
Lintz it's a union of nil or non-empty
collection events and of course the
empty vector is none of those things so
what's the first thing we want to do to
to support this code to support this
empty vector so why don't we just arrays
any instances of non empty in this slide
and then type check it ok so type
closure is telling us that our code is
not sufficient to avoid an error and we
knew that because there was a
nullpointerexception but we get a new
invocation error that tells us that the
second argument to multiply is being
passed a union of nil and int and we're
actually expecting a number so that's
that sounds pretty fishy this is
probably where the null pointer
exception came from and if we want to
convince ourselves that this is actually
possible let's simulate the program
let's replace our sequence parameter
with the empty vector so if we follow
through we check if the empty vector is
is a true value it is we go down the
venn branch ban we get first of the
empty vector which in closure is null
and that's where our null pointer came
from so this tells us that our our
conditional is insufficient to to
distinguish between our empty check is
not strong enough so any closure
programmer will tell you that you need
to use this function called seek and
let's have a look at the type so it's
it's very much like like next it takes a
union of nil and a collection of X and
returns nil or a non-empty sake of X and
we can see the subtle differences in the
example if we pass it a non empty
sequence it returns a true value if we
pass it a an empty sequence or nil it
returns a false value so ok let's let's
update this hmm it just kind of worked
so we updated the conditional and type
closure tells us that this code is not
going to throw a null pointer exception
so we'll get back to this point later on
but notice that we we only we didn't
need to add any extra annotations here
so just to convince us all this is
untyped closure and it works for all
three use cases
so type closure is an optional type
system
that catches type errors in real closure
code and the rest is talk will be
detailing exactly that claim so I jump
right in with an example let's just step
back for a minute and look at the
history of type closure where have we
come from it all kind of started closure
kind of 2011 I was giving a talk on core
logic and logic programming and somehow
will bird and Dan Friedman made their
way into the audience which is honestly
the coolest and most petrifying thing to
have happened if you're talking in front
of 300 people and it's your first
conference and you know you're lecturing
will burdened down Friedman about their
research so if they're in the audience
right now it's my research now so thank
God but if I wasn't worrying about
Wilburn and down Friedman judging me
which of course that they wouldn't
they're very nice people but if I wasn't
doing that I was collecting ideas for my
honors dissertation so here's a bunch of
closures at at closure conch and I was
basically asking these these closure
program is what is the what are the
problems that they're having with with
closure and what what are the the kinds
of tools that they want to see and this
idea of static typing kept coming up so
I had my direction so back I flied to
Perth exactly the other side of the
world and to my undergraduate University
the University of Western Australia and
this is the the campus at about sunset
you can see the Swan River beautiful
Swan River on the top right when I
wasn't observing the the lovely views
however I was writing type closure with
Rowand Davies and my thesis was that
type closure is both practical and
useful so that was in 2012 and the the
main product of that work was the
implementation of type closure which is
called core type so core type is the
actual implementation of type closure
and I use type closure as kind of an
umbrella term for the tooling and the
theory and the the checker so I might
accidentally interchange them Adobe to
give use hopefully
so something cool happened I got invited
back to closure Conger the next year to
present this so it kind of came full
circle which is pretty awesome but last
year this probably will interest the
most people in this room if you want to
fund your programming language feel free
to come talk to me because I've
successfully ran a crowdfunding campaign
to fund about a year of development on
type closure and I had 545 funders who
raised $35,000 and I'm sure some of you
in the audience right now thank you very
much I had a brilliant year and you know
I've it's brought me to to America
basically to start grad school but here
are some of the the companies that that
have donated well who funded my my year
and you might recognize some of them as
some closure companies one in particular
we're gonna have a look at their large
type closure code base later on and some
some statistics and some analysis so
we're on base now is Bloomington Indiana
which is what that text box says up
there and I've started my grad school
there and here's that the sample gates
which is the most photogenic place in in
Indiana University but cooler than that
is I get to work with Sam Tobin watch
that so in 2012 I had this problem I got
closure
I want types but there's also this cool
tool called tap racket which had this
problem we've got racket we want types
so I basically took most of this that
this amazing research and in theory and
applied it to to closure then you know
two to three years later I'm working for
him so that the future is bright so
we're at the present day where are we
now something exciting that's happening
in the closure world is this IDE called
cursive closure if you haven't used it
or if you're new to new to closure I
highly recommend trying it out I know
people who have dropped Emacs and vim
for it and you know I'm kind of on the
fence it's it's pretty cool
and this guy Colin Fleming he's
presenting it I closure conscious this
year so look out for that talk but why
I'm mentioning it now is that he's add
he's added support for type closure in
the IDE so here's one example of a
function application error style of
error that we saw before
we've moused over the the red squiggly
lines so hey we're in a statically typed
language now this is great the tooling
can actually make use of this and this
is something that's come out of left
field recently if you go to this URL
down the bottom cross co j dot info
you'll find this really cool tool that
has harvested all these github projects
written in closure and and linked them
together on the level of functions and
namespaces and and projects so we have
dependencies across different projects
of what functions get called so one cool
thing that francesco Bologna has added
is he's harvested the type closure
annotations and added them to the
closure core documentation so you can
see we've got the documentation format v
we've got some era d's and then we've
got the the read type annotation and
then some documentation so I can't not
mention my my very own vim plug-in if
you like vim check this out there is one
justification though this vim plug-in
does something that note no closure tool
has ever done which is if you mouse over
a particular expression it'll tell you
the type of the expression and that this
isn't implemented in the cursive cursive
one yet but hopefully it will be sewn so
this is this is a taste of the kinds of
things you can you can get from having a
statically typed language which we
probably all know but it's it's pretty
cool being able to do it in enclosure so
this year we've had to google Summer of
Code students one Minori Yamashita from
from japan he has worked on bringing
typed closure - closure script and thus
the JavaScript and desu from China has
been adding has been improving the type
inference and some of the more
interesting cases that we come across in
closure
so let's look let's look at some of the
details of type closure we had this idea
of occurrence typing so in closure when
we when we write closure code different
occurrences of the same name aren't
necessarily the same type right so if we
look at this this simple little function
that I'm that I have on this slide
there's Gen vacant either takes a number
or a vector and it tests if it's a
number if it is we go down the den
branch if it's not then we go down the
else branch but the reason this
inference technique is called occurrence
typing is because different occurrences
of the same variable down different
branches have different types so this is
kind of a flow typing idea so let's just
simulate what this program does if we
pass it five then we go down the venn
branch and then we then we end up with
this generated vector if we pass it a
vector then we go down the else branch
but notice the then branch is not well
typed so we need to understand that it's
not possible to go down this this first
branch and the secret here is that we
can add extra annotations to our
functions to communicate to type closure
exactly what our functions will do so
for example you can see here we've got
this number question mark that is a
predicate of num and this predicate of
num tells type closure if this if this
invocation is in the test position of a
conditional when we're down the then
branch you you should assume that the
first argument is a number otherwise
it's not a number and if you think back
to my example with seek before you could
you could put you could imagine what the
the different things that type closure
learns downloads to branches so if we
have a conditional on the seek of a
binding if we're down the then branch
that means that the the binding is is
non-empty if we're down the else branch
it means that it's either empty or nil
and that's basically there is literally
a type annotation and type closure that
says that and you can just plug into
this system as
you'd like in the same way here so
here's one of my favorite topics in type
closure it's this idea of a keyword map
if you've ever used closure you you'd be
familiar with with a keyword map so int
type closure we've modeled this with a
type called H map so it's basically a a
map with key word keys map to known
values and then we can we can type check
these sorts of these sorts of
invitations so if we follow the Assoc
the the associate the top the way to
read this is a social onto the empty map
key a to value B to value one key B to
foo and C to bars so this type closure
infers that this is of type H map with
Man three mandatory entries a B and M C
which have a non store and a and a sim
values so this will see in this next
slide this is the same way to write
these two these two types so there's a
if there's a quoted quoted map then
that's the same as just specifying
mandatory entries so let's combine H
maps with multi methods so multi methods
are a cool feature in closure it allows
you to do dispatch in a in an open
fashion
so type closure can can type check these
these multi methods this the first line
up the top says def alias expression and
then says that expression is a recursive
type and then what this what the when an
expression is it's basically an abstract
syntax tree that has two different to
two different representations so one it
can be an if node that has an a test of
n and an else expression
notice we just put these things in a
union so this is a union type and we can
also have a Const op which is it has a
Const keyword and a value that is a
number so this particular this
particular multi-method takes a an
expression as you can see on the
annotation it takes an expression and
then takes the function from number to
number and then returns another
expression and then it dispatches on the
OP key and that's what's happening on
the right of the DEF multi then so the
interesting thing is here that we know
particular information about the the
type of e in these two methods so
clearly the the type of the expression
of the first argument is going to be an
op with an if so when we D structure
this type closure should figure out
exactly which one of these two Union
cases it is and on this same with the
Const so if we get to the Const we know
that the we have the the Const heights
map union member so when we get to this
point Val is always going to be a number
so we can we can apply F to Val and it's
all type checking correctly so this
means we can have code like this that
that that type closure can toe is
correct so we we can say we have an if
expression with a a test then an else
and we want to increment all these or
all the other leaves and then yeah we
end up with a test two three four for
the different nodes so on to
polymorphism here's a little snippet
that I found on github someone was
playing around with core async so
core.typed and quarry sink work work
fairly well with each other this is a
function that takes a it takes a
function and then returns another
function that's lifted to the to the
level of channels so to understand this
let's look at the type annotation
so for all XY for all types X and for
all tech types wire it takes in a
function from X to wire and returns a
channel of X and returns a function that
takes the channel of X and returns a
channel of Y and you can see on this
bottom line we're actually using this
lift channel to make a channel that that
converts lowercase strings to uppercase
strings and interestingly we don't need
to to provide which X's and Y's in this
spot because we we use local type
inference so it turns out this isn't
quite enough to type-check most closure
idioms we need to go a little further so
here's the the motivating example for
this idea of variable arity polymorphism
so if you've ever used schemes map or a
rackets map or closures map you'll know
that you can pass a surprising number of
things to it and and it just does the
right thing so the rules are if you pass
a n number of collections your first
argument must have n number of
parameters so the cool thing about
variable arity polymorphism is that you
can express this type in just one one
type annotation that's basically like a
template that expands and shrinks as
needed so in this particular example we
have three three collections the first
one has nums second one has stirrers and
then the last one has boolean and you
can say that we have three parameters
corresponding to those two those
arguments there so we do have to
actually annotate this this function
because of the the rules of local type
inference we can't both look for the the
the type of map and define the type of
this function at the same time so that's
a little restriction that you have to
keep in mind we're actually using
closure and type closure and practice
so type closure doesn't actually add any
runtime mechanisms so closure does very
well with just def types and protocols
it does have records as well but they're
basically data types so type closure can
can
annotate these definitions so and then
check their their usages so we have a
protocol and add a protocol that has a
add method and it takes itself all
protocols have its own always take
itself always take the target this as
the first argument so we don't need we
don't need to annotate that but the this
the first the second argument the why is
a number and then we return another
adder so we can extend this in the def
type and all we need to do is annotate
that that field in the in a that X field
and then we can construct the death we
can constructed the DEF type and then
pass it to the protocol as we like and
this type checks in in type closure so
finally in this section we have Java
intro so type closure type closure like
closure works fairly well with Java
so here's can anyone spot the bug in
this code so we get the parent of a file
and then we get the parent of the parent
what are we going to get if we pass a
parent pass the file that doesn't have a
grandparent now point out excellent
so type closure tells us this and this
is the way it tells you so you cannot
call an instance method with a nillable
type so it knows that you could possibly
do this but it's not convinced that this
will avoid null pointer exceptions you
can see this is different from the way
that Java traits reference types so in
other words reference types in type
closure are non nullable and not nil and
null are exactly the same but they have
that they're completely separated those
two concepts then we can get back
nullable types by simply shoving them
into a Union like here so the way to fix
this we all know how to do it just check
if if p1 is is an instance of a file and
if it's if it is then get the parent so
type closures convinced that this this
will type check
that this won't throw a
nullpointerexception at runtime so let's
move on to our case study so Circle CI
is a continuous integration company and
this is the web app they I think
recently they've allowed adding open
source tooling open source continuous
integration of arbitrary github projects
so give it a shot it's pretty cool but
they were pretty excited with type
closure so if you if you go and read
their their blog post on type closure
you can tell that they they were really
waiting for a tool like this so they
they've been using type closure for over
a year now and here's an example of a
developer hailing core types apparently
but they have about 50,000 lines of
closure code and around about 10,000
lines of it is in type closure so
breaking that down it's not it's
actually not that easy to separate
closure and type closure code because
they're kind of intermingled so we had
this concept of an a an annotation
that's not checked so when we add an
annotation to a top-level binding we can
tell closure to either check the binding
that check the definition or not check
it so it turns out 46 percent of around
about 600 annotations are checked so
it's probably at probably about 5,000
lions well I think it was six or seven
thousand lines of type closure code are
actually being checked in in circle CI
so the the portion in red there is that
the number of annotations done are not
checked so this means that type closure
has idioms that it cannot check and
circle CI is saying okay let's just
leave this as unchecked and then wait
for a future version and unfortunately
this 22 percent on the top left is also
known as yak shaving because to annotate
your project you have to annotate a
third-party library
so let's look at a bit of sample code
from circle see is code base so they
have this function encrypt key pair when
they connect to Heroku for example they
have to do with do with private keys so
they want this this key pair this
encrypt key pair to take an unencrypted
key pair and return and encrypted key
pair so let's have a look at those those
types so we just have Alice's as we saw
before so we have a hatch map for the
raw key pair and it has two entries it
has a public key which is raw so
unencrypted and then a private key which
is wrong but it also has this extra
completeness property which says that
this haitch map cannot have any more any
less case this is fully specified so it
always always has length two always has
these keys so an encrypted key pair is
the same as a raw key pair except we've
removed the private key and excuse me
and we've replaced it with an encrypted
private key which has another type so if
you notice on the the third line of code
here
we're Assoc to map after dis ocean so
what this does this dissociate key
returns the key pair without the private
key right so this is pretty integral to
making sure that we don't leak out the
raw private key so what happens if we
forget to do that so type closure tells
us that we were expecting an encrypted
private key it encrypted key pair but we
actually got a hatch map with three
entries which was we had the encrypted
key pair with the encrypted private key
we've got the unencrypted public key but
we've also got the unencrypted private
private key so something that's
interesting that kind of validates using
H maps to to model how closure code
works is this statistic here that out of
64 type alias --is that circles CI users
about 60% of them just using H maps so
they have functions everywhere that just
take key
Maps return keyword maps are such things
do such things so so yeah I'm that's
that's a good thing and so let's have a
look at the future so we've we've seen
we've seen the cool things that type
closure can do what's next so one thing
I'm sure a lot of people in this room
would love to see is a closure script
type checker because the the errors the
runtime errors in closure closure script
oh well just as bad worse you know it
depends who you're talking to as closure
so you get all the typical JavaScript
errors and this is a pragmatic decision
it's it's mostly performance related so
static analysis is a good thing to have
here so as I was saying before we had
our google Summer of Code student Minori
working on this problem and he was
basically starting off similar to other
statically typed JavaScript
languages to harvest typescript code
sorry typescript annotations and use
them to type-check JavaScript JavaScript
Interop so this is something that's
that's on the cards and should should be
bearing fruit soon so when I started off
implementing type racket in type closure
I basically picked the easy bit so this
is the hard bit let me show you what the
hard bit is so if we have untyped code
and it goes over to type land and
something goes wrong you know everything
spazzes out this basically means our
error messages are completely have gone
haywire what we really want to happen is
that when we call our untyped closure
code that we protect it so when this
happens you know the world doesn't fall
apart right and this this means that we
get good error messages and this is
exactly what type racket does and it
turns out going the other way is just as
important
so if we want to pass our typed code to
anti planned well you know that the
world could fall over but you know we
still get a good error message so this
is a very interesting problem that we're
going to be working on in the near
future so here's a call to action if you
own a closure library annotator add type
annotations to it so people like the
circle see I don't need to do their 20%
time of yak shaving just to use their
library and if you don't have your own
and it's a if you don't have your own
library adopt a library and I'm find me
on IRC you find me you know at this
conference I'll I will tell you exactly
my ideas of the best way to annotate
your library and it's not it doesn't
mean that you have to rewrite your
application in type closure it basically
amounts to you have a separate namespace
that's you know my name space dot typed
write that a type closure programmer
would would require in their name space
and it would it would automatically add
all the annotations of your library so
in conclusion type closure works in
production if you want to start using it
you can visit type closure org and I
strongly encourage you to annotate your
libraries or adopt a library today thank
you
questions it is the code generator using
any of these annotations so basically
type closure it's a thin layer of macros
over-over closure so what that means is
we can reuse the compiler we can reuse
all tooling but unfortunately there is
no way to insert this information back
into the compilation process so if you
can imagine the compilation process
going you know reading analyzing and
emission right what type closure does is
it reuses that those machineries but it
goes read analyze and then type check
and then you know that the the arrow
just kind of keeps going and it can't
inform the so it's a bit of it's a
technical issue type racket actually
does really well in that area and it
improves the numeric performance quite
considerably yep when am I going to have
dependent types there is someone working
on dependent types in type racket and I
don't understand it yet so I don't know
sorry yeah about yeah ten percent sounds
about right so what is the overhead of
annotating your code so it really
depends on on the code it it seems to be
you can either annotate it easily or
it's impossible so or let me refer you
can either annotate it easily or type
closure is not good enough yet to
annotate it let's let's keep it at that
so yeah about ten percent overhead and
it's mostly annotations in positions
that are useful like function parameters
top level bindings these data types
protocols and the things that people can
use like in this cross coj as
documentation so that we don't often
need to have silly annotations just to
to please the type checker but you know
you do have to do that every night again
yep
so can I describe some of the
implementation details around
implementing gradual typing for type
closure so it's hard so if you've ever
used closure you know that there is no
concept of encapsulation you know you if
you use a vibe from a namespace you just
kind of require it into your into your
namespace you don't copy the value just
literally use the same bar from over
here so you can do whatever you want
right so there's a problem right if we
want to use an untyped to closure VAR it
would be great if we could you know
simulate using it but unfortunately
we're actually using that var so we
can't simply you know encapsulate it in
a bubble because that means every code
that that touches that var has to go
through that bubble and that's not what
we want we only want the bubble to
encapsulate the the code if we go across
the boundary right and DEF types are
final enough said how do you proxy a
final class I would love to know so I'm
learning some bytecode manipulations to
solve that problem
so yeah I mean that that'll take me
months to to solve so there's a couple
yeah
so generic a Java generics plan to be
supported no because it turns out that
this this works really well and I was
very happy not to have to worry about
type variables existential bounded
polymorphism and you know that that's
enough I I'm done so it's it's on that
said there is an implementation for the
the common language runtime which I'm
told does use generics so that I may
have to solve that problem I may be
forced to solve it but if I can avoid it
then I will so generate the static types
so the question is so there's this
library called prismatic schema which is
kind of like a contracts library it's a
popular library and particular that
there are libraries that bridges the gap
between core types and schema because
you don't want to to write the same
annotation twice you don't want to write
the other contract and the annotation so
I like to think of so that there are
libraries that that bridge the gap here
by creating a common syntax and
basically you write the annotation once
it generates the schema and it generates
the the type annotation so this this
works it would be nice however if type
closure just automatically understood
the schema and it's actually close it's
almost there the problem is that schemas
syntax is is actually not amenable to
these H map concepts because in schema a
map contract is a keyword map so great
you say I want a map contract a to none
B to string right but they also have a
special key that they had for optional
values
so unfortunately type closure it doesn't
have this concept of anything other than
a keyword in the H map of so it's that
close so
there are ways to improve this so you
don't need it doesn't need to be done
and it's really you know tight closure
is the weak link here the static
analysis unsurprisingly needs to improve
so it can be done automatically could be
done the other questions
yep yeah I hear there's this language
called racket and and why don't I first
port the oh yeah well unfortunately I
don't own closure so I don't one of the
goals was to work with regular the
regular closure compiler and I I don't
really want to I guess I was going to
say complicate but it would definitely
be more complicated to use rackets what
complected okay yeah
so in practice that that's just not
going to happen so I need yeah I've been
dealt these cards and I need to work
with the macro system but of course it
would be amazing if we had this racket
like ecosystem of creating languages
where we could intercept the boundaries
between languages very precisely but
it's just not the case I think that's it
cool thank you